intel 和软银合作的Sign Memory公司
真的是脑洞大开
高频宽记忆体本来是只有水平堆叠
而Z型甲角记忆体Zen Memory竟然可以
各位曲博科技教师的观众朋友大家好
我是曲博
最近intel又有大创新
和软银合作投资Sign Memory公司
计划推出Z型甲角记忆体Zen
想要取代高频宽记忆体HBM
我们都知道在人工智慧伺服器里面
HBM是最重要的记忆体
但是呢这种记忆体必须用先进封装堆叠多层的晶片
而且良率偏低
再加上HBM的记忆体容量也不够大
到底有什么方法可以来解决HBM记忆体良率和容量的问题呢
到底这个ZAM记忆体有什么特别之处
今天我们来和大家谈谈这个题目
在今天的影片开始之前
我们应该要先了解intel和软银合作的Z型夹角记忆体ZAM
真正的挑战不会只有在记忆体本身
因为当人工智慧的运算越来越庞大
晶片记忆体封装散热功耗讯号的完整性
全部都会被绑在一个系统里面一起接受考验
也就是说未来谁能够更早预测到系统的行为
更快找到设计的瓶颈
谁就能够在高效能运算和人工智慧硬体竞争里面取得优势
而这个也正是今年的ANSYS Simulation World很值得关注的地方
ANSYS Simulation World将在8月12日新竹的风艺洗来灯饭店登场
这次活动的重点就是要一起探索人工智慧的模拟
多物理模拟以及数位软身的技术
如何帮助工程团队在产品开发的早期
就能够先看到系统级的关键问题
尤其是在半导体专场的部分
里面涵盖了先进封装的焊点预测
多物理流固偶合分析
类比机体电路设计的最佳化
以及封装设备开发
失效分析等等议题
如果你本身在半导体
封装设备或研发相关领域工作
那么这些内容
应该都会让你非常有感
像我们今天即将要谈到的
HBM和ZAM记忆体
其实背后就牵扯到
非常多系统的挑战
包括记忆体频宽能不能提高
封装结构能不能承受
晶片热量能不能带走
运算功耗能不能降低
甚至不同晶片间的互联
是不是稳定
这些问题如果等到实体的产品
晶片做出来才能确定
成本就会非常高
所以透过模拟工具
把这些设计风险提前摊开来看
对半导体先进封装
系统设计
智慧移动和电子电力等产业来说
就会变得越来越重要
如果你是工程师
研发团队
半导体的从业人员
或是想要了解人工智慧时代
背后的真正工程挑战
非常推荐你来报名
Simulation World 台湾2026
活动资讯和报名连结
我会放在影片的下方
还有留言置顶处
欢迎大家报名
接下来我们就来看看
Intel最新发表的Z型夹角记忆体ZAM
有什么特别的地方吧
所以我们今天的题目是
Intel与软银合作推出
Z型夹角记忆体ZAM
大战高频宽记忆体HBM
厉害在哪里
首先我们介绍高频宽的记忆体
不等同于高频宽记忆体HBM
再来我们介绍Z型夹角记忆体ZAM
形成是源自于三股力量的汇聚
以及Intel和软银旗下的Sign Memory合作
商业化四世代的记忆体技术
以及Z型夹角记忆体ZAM
定义出一条非细穿孔的高频宽记忆体路径
再来我们介绍高频宽记忆体HBM的本质限制
以及Z型夹角记忆体ZAM的创新思路
最后我们介绍Intel的专利
高容量记忆体的垂直堆叠封装架构
我们今天的这套来源是Semi Vision Research发表在Substack
题目是Zen能否取代HBM
Intel和软银推动颠覆性的记忆体架构
同时我们也参考Intel发表的专利
来介绍到底什么是Z型夹角记忆体
首先我们和大家谈谈高频宽的记忆体
不等同于高频宽记忆体HBM
随着全球人工智慧运算的竞赛加速
真正的瓶颈已经不再是图形处理器GPU的架构
而是记忆体的物理极限
其中高频宽记忆体HBM的产能
目前仍然有SK海力4三星电子和美光科技严格的掌控
因为它的供应很紧张
也就是供应量有限
定价的能力强
以及扩产的周期缓慢
最后就造成2024年到2026年之间
人工智慧的供应链出现反复性的结构失调
也就是运算的能力充足
但是记忆体却受限
造成记忆体价格大涨
这个并非短期产品循环的问题
而是由单一主导技术路径
所造成的市场结构性锁定
也就是说呢
高频宽记忆体
如果等同于使用动态随机存取记忆体
垂直堆叠起来的高频宽记忆体HBM的话
那么供应链的控制
就会集中在三家公司手中
这样子记忆体缺货的问题就很难解决
因此这一次Intel和软银
与Sign Memory合作
推出Z型夹角记忆体
这是一种特殊的封装方式
上面这个图是
Z型夹角记忆体
在探针卡上面测试的情形
而Z型夹角记忆体Zen的形成
是源自于三股力量的汇聚
正是在这样高度集中
但是结构脆弱的格局当中
Intel和软银合作的Sign Memory公司
就推出了Z型夹角记忆体
Z-Angle Memory
这个计划就具有战略意义
这不仅仅是另外一种动态随机存取记忆体DRAM的规格
更应该被理解成一个人工智慧时代的记忆体架构创新平台
它的形成是源自于三股力量的汇聚
首先第一股力量就是成立真正的驱动力由于供应链风险的管理不只是技术进步这个例行夹角记忆体的诞生不只是源于我们有更好的记忆体
而是来自一个更紧迫的认知
也就是人工智慧的基础设施
不能够持续依赖只有两家
韩国记忆体的供应商
第二股力量是对英特尔而言
这是本质上的平台控制权问题
如果未来人工智慧伺服器
都被锁定在图形处理器
GPU与高频宽记忆体HBM的架构中
那么记忆体供应的节奏
就会近视于韩国厂商的资本支出周期
也就是目前的高频宽记忆体
都是由韩国的厂商掌控
这样未来
Intel就会被韩国的厂商制约
而平台创新的速度
会近视于受限高频宽记忆体的细穿孔制程演进
这个就等同于将人工智慧运算的节奏交给外部控制
对于正在建立先进制成
和资料中心生态系的intel来说
在战略上不可接受
换句话说
intel并不想被两家韩国的厂商掌控
第三股力量是对软银而言
这是投资结构风险的问题
人工智慧的投资
已经从软体模型转向基础设施的层级
如果运算基础受制于高频宽记忆体HBM
那么人工智慧的投资报酬率ROI的周期
将会被绑定到记忆体产业的循环
而机架的密度和功耗经济性就会变得不可预测
因此软银也急着想要有一种新的技术来取代高频宽记忆体HBM
因此Z型夹角记忆体Zen在本质上就是一种基础设施对冲的机制
它存在的目的就是可以打破对于高频宽记忆体HBM单一路径的依赖
因此软银和Intel合作与Sign Memory一起推出商业化的次世代记忆体技术
Sign Memory公司是软银在2024年12月成立的子公司
致力于推动次世代记忆体技术的研发
目标是在2027年推出原型的产品
并且在2029年要实现商业化
透过这种例行夹角记忆体的技术
双方将致力于提升资料中心
在大型人工智慧模型训练和推论中
所需要的大容量高频宽资料处理能力
同时还要改善运算效能并且降低功耗
根据日经新闻报道
Sign Memory公司和Intel的目标
是要将功耗降到目前的高频宽记忆体产品的一半
Sign Memory公司的社长三口音
也在东京举行的技术活动中表示
这个计划将会解决散热效能和供应的问题
并且认为这个技术在某种意义上
是一种颠覆性的挑战
Intel参与开发的Fayman也指出
这个专案可能带来比高频宽记忆体
更低成本的记忆体技术
接下来我们和大家谈谈
Z形夹角记忆体Zen定义一条
非细穿孔的高频宽记忆体路径
Intel长期的和桑迪亚国家实验室
合作开发次世代动态随机存取记忆体
DRAM的结合技术
这是一种先进封装技术
根据官方的说明
传统的高频宽记忆体HBM解决方案
往往需要在频宽和容量之间做出权衡
而这种次世代的动态随机存取记忆体
结合技术称为NGDB
Next Generation DRAM Bounding
它设计的目的就是要消除这个限制
因此Z型夹角记忆体的关键是在封装技术的创新
它仍然是使用动态随机存取记忆体
D-RAM这个技术的目的是在高频宽记忆体
HBM和传统的动态随机存取记忆体
D-RAM之间建立效能桥接
同时可以提升能源效率
Intel 强调这种次世代动态随机存取记忆体的结合技术
NGDB 展现了一种结合创新记忆体架构
和革命性封装制成的设计
可以显速的优化动态随机存取记忆体的性能和成本
并且有望为低功耗的记忆体带来变革的机会
因此Z型夹角记忆体Zen的企业定位
与其说是记忆体供应商不如说是架构整合平台
因为传统的记忆体公司发展入境
通常是先做动态随机存取记忆体低润的设计
然后扩建晶元厂
然后用每个位元的成本来竞争
而Z型夹角记忆体
类似于记忆体架构智慧财产权权的公司
加上三维制造协同平台
它是透过一种新的方式
也就是非细穿孔的高频宽记忆体路径
包括架构专利的设计
三维堆叠的实体结构设计
以及和晶元代工厂共同开发的制成窗口
这个也说明了为什么Z型夹角记忆体
必须以独立实体的形式存在
如果他隶属既有的记忆体制造商
那么这个发展路线就会立刻
和高频宽记忆体更生低估的既有利益产生冲突
意思就是说这种新的封装技术
不应该由现有的海力士三星或美光来开发
不然的话就会和现有的高频宽记忆体产生利益冲突
这样就不容易成功
换句话说
Z型夹角记忆体不是次世代高频宽记忆体
而是一条去高频宽记忆体化的路径
换句话说
Intel的目标是希望发展出Z型夹角记忆体之后
就可以取代掉高频宽记忆体一部分的市场
那么高频宽记忆体HBM的本质限制到底有哪些呢
首先高频宽记忆体的核心是透过细穿孔
TSD将很多层的动态随机存取记忆体晶片垂直堆叠
再透过中介层和逻辑晶片
也就是图形处理器连接
但是当技术演进到高频宽记忆体
第四版HBM4的时候
已经逐渐逼近三个根本的限制
也就是目前的高频宽记忆体
是利用许多动态随机存取记忆体的晶片回植堆叠经由细穿孔互相连接但是当堆叠的乘数越来越多的时候就慢慢接近极限
其中第一个限制是结构限制
高频繁记忆体的堆叠
依赖每颗晶片上面有数千个细穿孔
TSB这些垂直互联会占用宝贵的细面积
降低实际可用的记忆体密度
同时高细穿孔密度也会削弱晶圆的机械强度
提高翘驱硬力集中和精力破裂的风险
使得堆叠高度增加的时候
良率敏感度就急剧上升
造成良率降低
意思就是说HBM3使用1024个矽穿孔
到HBM4使用2048个矽穿孔
这些矽穿孔都会占用矽晶片的面积
就使得原来制作动态随机存取
记忆体的记忆单元数量变少
意思就是说
当堆叠的记忆体晶片数目越多
讯号就必须经由细穿孔对外通讯
HBM31具有1024个细穿孔
到HBM4具有2048个细穿孔
而这些细穿孔会占用掉许多面积
造成记忆体晶片的记忆单元减少
第二个限制是热限制
当堆叠层数增加到12层16层
甚至更多层的时候
中间的晶片会形成热死区
这些热量需要穿越多层的低导热材料才能够排出
就会造成温度T度热点还有资料保持能力下降
散热效率会随着堆叠晶片的数目
以及高度增加呈现非线性的下降
就会迫使频率降低或者进行严格的热节流
意思就是说当高频宽记忆体堆叠的晶片数目越来越多
中间的晶片热量就没有办法散出
这个时候就会被迫要降低存取的速度
或者进行严格的热管理
第三个限制是功耗限制
这些讯号呢
需要经由微凸块MicroBump
或者导线重布成RDL
或者细穿孔TSD的通道对外传输
而每一层的记忆体晶片
都会增加电阻电容还有寄生电感
这个就会使得输入输出的功耗
随着频宽提升而快速上升
成为系统总功耗里面重要的部分
会降低整体的能源效率
意思就是说
这每一层的记忆体晶片之间
传输讯号都会产生电阻
电容和寄生电感
当记忆体晶片的层数越多
所造成的电阻电容寄生电感
就会越严重
同时造成功耗越高
为了最大限度的提高记忆体的频宽
在设计的时候需要考虑
超过1000个输入输出界面的限制条件
也就是HBM31需要1024个系穿孔
HBM4需要2048个系穿孔
由于静态功耗过高
精力内的终端电阻不被允许
而且对于讯号完整性来说
输入输出电容必须最小化
同时在高频宽记忆体最下方的基底晶片
BestDot也就是动态随机存取
记忆体的控制晶片
必须满足作为缓冲器的要求
要减少输入输出的电容
同时具有更好的电晶体表现
以及更简单的输入输出设计
并且和核心晶片
也就是处理器之间要共享输入输出
由于上面这些限制
即使在新一代的产品中
增加的也是输入输出的频宽
而不是位元资料速率
因此HBM31和HBM4
每一个接角的速度
大约是8到10Gbps并没有增加
但是因为接角数目增加一倍
所以总频宽增加一倍
接下来我们和大家谈谈Z型夹角记忆体ZAMP的创新思路
这种技术的核心概念可以简化成一句话
就是不要到处砖孔
而是建立一条中央主干道
第一个概念是单一通道架构
Z型夹角记忆体采用单一中央通道来传输电源和讯号
取代高频宽记忆体的风潮式细穿孔网路
改为单轴主干的结构
这样带来的效果包括动态随机存取记忆体DRAM的有效储存面积提升30%以上
因为少掉了细窗口
所以可以在记忆体晶片上配置更多的记忆单元
讯号路径缩短可以降低延迟
而且机械结构更稳定
可以支撑更高的堆叠
也就是可以堆叠更多的记忆体
这个不是自成优化
而是记忆体实体架构的重新变更
第二个概念是原生热管效应
在过去高频宽记忆遵循堆叠越高核心越热的规则
而Z型夹角记忆体的中央通道类似垂直热管
使得核心的热量可以更容易直接导出
实验的数据显示在相同运算负载下
Z型夹角记忆体的功耗可能只有高频宽记忆体的50%
对于人工智慧资料中心而言
这个已经不是渐进式的改良
而是机甲密度等级的改变
第三个概念是无焊突点建核
例行夹角记忆体是采用直接系对系的混合建核技术
而不是微突块
因此讯号不再经过焊点
氧化层或者不连续的材料界面
而是在接近原子等级的界面传输
可以大幅降低电阻和寄生电感
接下来我们就来看一看英特尔的专利
高容量记忆体的垂直堆叠封装架构
英特尔最近公开了美国的专利
题目是采用垂直堆叠精力
来实现高容量记忆体的封装架构
描述了一种和传统高频宽记忆体
明显不同的封装架构
这个架构不再只是将动态随机存取
记忆体晶片垂直堆叠
并且放在系统介板的旁边
而是透过模组化垂直堆叠与系统及整合方式扩展记忆体的容量和频宽这个代表记忆体密度实现的方式发生了根本的转变这个图是英特尔的专利110是细晶片
12是细晶片上的主动元件
可能是电晶体或记忆体
102是导线重新分布成
其中122是垂直同导线
120是水平同导线
104是借电材料
也就是绝缘体
124是同导线
右边是横截面积
我们如果将左边的晶片翻转90度
就变成右边
110是矽晶片
112是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
102是导线重布层
当然我们也可以在矽晶片和主动元件层的上面
制作导线重布层
同时经由矽窗孔在矽晶片的背面也制作导线重布层
102A是正面的导线重布层
102B是背面的导线重布层
右边是横截面
将左边这个图翻转90度
就变成右边这个图
110是细晶片
12是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
102A是正面的导线重布层
102B是背面的导线重布层
当然我们也可以用两个晶片
面对面上下堆叠
110A是上面的细晶片
110B是下面的细晶片
12A是上面的主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
12B是下面的细晶片
同时将102导线重步层
制作在两个晶片的中间
右边是横截面
将左边的图翻转90度
变成右边的图
所以110A跟110B是细晶片
12A和12B是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
102是导线重步层夹在中间
将刚才的细晶片旋转90度之后
100是细晶片
102是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
104是导线重布层
将许多的动态随机存取记忆体晶片
在水平方向上重复堆叠
经由截面积连接到下面的细晶片
这个时候102的导线重布层
就可以连接到水平的细晶片上的导线重布层
这样就可以大幅的扩充动态随机存取记忆体的容量
换句话说
垂直的导线重步层和水平的导线重步层
经由横截面互相连接
最后就变成下面这个图
在垂直的晶片上
110是细晶片
12是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
102是导线重步层
而水平的晶片
316是细晶片
310是主动元件
包括电晶体或记忆体
314是导线重步层
换句话说
垂直的晶片有垂直的导线重步层
水平的晶片有水平的导线重布层
经由横截面互相连接
这样就可以堆叠许多垂直的晶片
在一个水平晶片上
大幅的增加动态随机存取记忆体的堆叠密度
而且这些导线重布层
更容易把热量传递出去
上面提到的这种次世代动态随机存取记忆体
结合技术NGDP测试的组件
横截面示意图就可以看出
它不是传统的组装方式
使用8片新型的次世代动态随机存取记忆体
结合技术的架构
这种晶圆被垂直建合在基底晶圆之上
并且透过一种替代性的一次性通孔结构进行连接
下面这个示意图就是将许多的动态随机存取记忆体
垂直晶片堆叠在水平晶片上
再和中间这8个图形处理器GPU
整合在同一个导线载板上
这样的堆叠密度会比现有的高频宽记忆体高很多
这个图则是从上往下看的俯视图
中间这八个是图形处理器GPU
旁边这些就是动态随机存取记忆体
白色的是垂直堆叠的晶片
灰色的是水平堆叠的晶片
导线重布成经由截面机互相连接
这样就可以大幅增加动态随机存取记忆体的容量
这个图是从侧面看
中间这两个是图形处理器GPU
这个是垂直堆叠的动态随机存取记忆体晶片
这个是水平堆叠的晶片
左边和右边可以堆叠更多动态随机存取记忆体
再经由导线载板互相连接
当然左边右边还可以再堆叠更多的动态随机存取记忆体
或是将动态随机存取记忆体堆叠在中间
将图形处理器GPU堆叠在左边和右边
利用这样的方式可以堆叠更多的动态随机存取记忆体
大幅增加记忆体的容量
这个就是intel的专利所提到的先进封装技术
暗线有高频宽记忆体垂直堆叠的方式差异很大
从前面的介绍
大家会发现intel和软银合作的Sign Memory公司
真的是脑洞大开
高频宽记忆体本来是只有水平堆叠
而Z型夹角记忆体Zen Memory
竟然可以水平堆完垂直堆
垂直堆完再水平堆
用这样的方式呢
大幅的增加动态随机存取记忆体的容量
当然在实物上
我相信水平和垂直的晶片要堆叠对准
难度是非常的高
因此在技术上还有很多困难要突破
我们呢拭目以待
看看什么时候这样的记忆体可以上市
甚至可以取代高频宽记忆体
好我们今天的节目到这边
大家对于Z型夹角记忆体ZenMemory
有任何问题
欢迎大家发表在影片的下方
我们再来讨论
谢谢大家
晚安
拜拜